you were on to promote a movie uh my
father the hero with gerard depardieu
and you came on the show and i just was
looking at this picture today and
thinking oh my gosh
you look you look gorgeous and adorable
as always like an idiot i look like i'm
having a dirt no you don't what do you
mean i think you've got a jacket look at
it it's like four times too big i guess
that was the fashion was it the fashion
it was 93
yeah so what is that look at is that
like a planet hollywood planet hollywood
jean jacket yeah that's what i made all
my guests wear back then well hollywood
was a big deal guys it was a big thing
but i know i was just looking at myself
and i look like i'm melting like hello
15 year old
and you're like oh well i have to have
to be here long with him
now what were you like uh at that age i
mean obviously very you were
very attractive
kid you must have been confident no not
at all no i was um i was a real doormat
uh
in those years and i got i was very late
bloomer
so by like 14 and 15 i just was super
flat chested oh the boys made a lot of
fun of me the boys made fun of me they
did my favorite was hey katie would you
wear shoes if you didn't have feet to
which you reply well no of course not
and they said then why are you wearing a
bra oh my god
who are these jerks harsh i could give
you their names i want to fight them
first of all i like how that insult
takes a long time hey
question for you right and you and it
sets you up completely you have your own
feet would you in fact wear a shoe yeah
uh well okay there's more
yeah
that's terrible that insult takes 20
minutes yeah but i spent you know the
next however many months and years
praying and praying and praying to get
big boobs like that's you
big boobs
like i fasted for big boobs i don't know
like
i grew up mormon and once a month you
have like fast and testimony meeting and
you're supposed to you know skip two
meals and fast for things that matter
oh my god you know
good health and all the safety yeah i
think family i think world peace is
supposed to be in there
you know that sort of thing i fasted for
big boobs that's it for big boobs yep i
cut out photos from the victoria's
secret catalog of the body i liked and
then put the head i liked on top of it
but here's the i do that that's the
creepy part
good i'm glad i'm not alone yeah but the
problem is that it it my mother to this
day swears it worked which is
i don't know how i feel about god
god is like quiet i could there's
disease and ruin everywhere
but this one wants big boobs i must
focus yeah and uh i just said yeah but
the problem is no one warns you that um
well this is a lot of information but
with with real
larger sized breasts comes issues the
victoria's secret models don't have like
gravity and
uh and bigger butts and bigger thighs
and so i've had to spend the rest of my
life with big boobs trying to make sure
everything stays tight and where it's
supposed to so you think that's god's
revenge
i do you wanted these big boobs have
some gravity right he's like you're that
shallow
travis
i do not think this is something you
have to worry about you look absolutely
fantastic
i'm guessing the boys stopped teasing
you when you well no development then i
went away to do a movie which and then i
came back to on your show when i was i
think 16 yeah to promote a movie i did
called uh under siege two with steven
seagal yep and i played his niece so he
wanted me to dye my hair brown so i
looked more like him
and uh you should listen to steven
seagal when he gives you advice yeah
especially when it's to look more like
him yeah yeah yeah you know what your
problem is katherine heigl you do not
look enough like me yeah stephen seagal
yeah it was
an interesting time to say the least but
i when i got back to school it was a
six-month shoot that's when they spend
tons of money on these kind of movies
and it was six months later i got back
and i had like doubled my bra size so
now i could wear a bra you
[Laughter]
i don't think i don't think those guys
are in our audience right now well they
couldn't let's go to the conan show and
see if she developed maybe he could be
watching oh my gosh no yeah yeah
it could be so so that and then the boys
noticed you yeah well no then they all
the whole school the rumor was that i
had gone to la and had a boob job
really yeah
so i would just i thought that was
hilarious the idea that at 15 or 16 i
went to i guess it's not that out of the
ordinary i think sadly that is something
that some people in my day that was not
something people did so i would just
wear the tightest shirts i could and
flaunt it as much as i could and get
your revenge got my revenge fantastic
revenge a revenge where everyone wins